[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday July 23rd
and today we're going to learn how many
q-tips we can put in an ear one two
three four five six six q-tips fit in
one year are the new floors gone yet
thank you may be wondering why I'm lying
in bed looking a little feverish it's
because I am a little feverish this
weekend the Yeti and I went to the
sandwich antiques fair which is located
in Sandwich Illinois and we got a lot of
stuff for the new house like for
instance we got a dining room table and
we got this weird TV from the 1960s that
looks kind of like a divers helmet but
it's not just antiques you can get at
the sandwich Antiques Fair you can also
get upper respiratory infections with
fever and achiness so that's nice
we could have gotten this good-looking
mountain dew sign but it was too
expensive I do kind of feel like my
innards are being tickled but not in a
good way the one thing we couldn't find
in Sandwich Illinois and this was a bit
of a surprise to me a sandwich
all I wanted was sliced turkey on white
bread was that too much to ask sandwich
Illinois do you think it just occurred
to me that maybe I shouldn't have made
this video maybe my flu is transmittable
via a video blog that would suck I don't
want to make you sick but the marriage
to Brotherhood 2.0 is kind of an
sickness and health richer poor till
2000 they do us part kind of thing so
I'll see you tomorrow